astrazeneca dans l'embarras ces derniers
jours plusieurs pays ont suspendu au
moins partiellement les injections du
vaccin de la firme britannique
j'ordonne qu'astrazeneca le vaccin
britannique soit suspendue jusqu'à ce
que nous ayons une confirmation écrit de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
un avis précis et clairement confirmé
sur la question de savoir si oui ou non
il peut être utilisé d'ici là nous
l'arrêterons mais parmi les nouveautés
qui inquiète des allergies sévères qui
s'ajoutent aux possibles effets
secondaires plus alarmant encore la
crainte d'un risque aggravé de caillots
sanguins
un dernier point sur lequel le groupe
pharmaceutique s'est voulu rassurant
les chiffres sur ce type de problème
médical sont beaucoup plus faible chez
ceux qui sont vaccinées comparé à ce qui
serait attendu dans la population dans
son ensemble
il n'y a pour autant pas de raison de ne
pas utiliser le vaccin d'astrazeneca
affirme à ce stade l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
pour l'heure la france à l'image des
instances européennes compétentes décide
de maintenir l'utilisation du sérum
estimant son bénéfice supérieur aux
risques qu'ils impliquent les avantages
du vaccin continue de l'emporter sur ces
risques et le vaccin peut continuer à
être administrés pendant que l' enquête
sur les cas de thromboembolie est en
cours pendant ce temps l' agence
brésilienne de régulation a
définitivement autorisé l'utilisation de
ce vaccin
une décision qui intervient alors que
les négociations entre brasilia et
freezer n'ont toujours pas abouti